you
[Music]
hey everybody its Charlie I've gotten a
lot of requests to do more videos for
the boys this is gonna be my video about
black noir so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos I'll be doing a bunch of
season 2 videos too they're almost
halfway done filming season 2 so they
might premiere it early next year and I
will do a giveaway for amazon prime
memberships because you do need those to
actually watch the series so all you
have to do to enter that is just be a
subscriber and leave your best boys
season 2 theory on the video this big
epic fight is obviously their version of
what if Batman fought Wolverine because
black noir is their very obvious parody
of the Batman character and they give
the female of the species
a lot of Wolverine like abilities she's
very animalistic in the way she fights
just like Wolverine so we'll go through
all their powers and a whole bunch of
Easter eggs there's so many funny and
WTF moments with all these characters
but particularly black noir
but obviously careful for spoilers if
you have not seen the series yet because
we'll be talking about stuff from all
over all of the episodes starting with
number 10 black noir vs. the female of
the species
aka Kimiko because we learned that her
name is Kimiko so when I say this is
their Batman vs. Wolverine there are a
lot of parodies of the Justice League
characters because the seven like unite
the seven is a very literal parody of
the Justice League but a lot of the
other characters in the series and some
of them that we haven't met yet are also
parodies of Avengers characters like
they have a version of Thor that's
called storm front that we'll probably
meet next season and if you think some
of the characters that you met during
season one are bad he's way worse and
way more powerful nine black noir is
only using knives throwing weapons in
his hand to hand combat martial arts
with his body armor but because the
female has a measure of super strength
she's able to use her fingers like
razor-sharp claws Wolverine stop she's
able to tear through his body armor with
those regular fingernails and cut him so
a lot of people are like wait a minute
why is she able to cut him because if
you've read the comics you know that
he's supposed to have a measure of
invulnerability this is one of the
reasons why I think they've
significantly changed his character and
I'll talk about that as we go along
through Easter eggs Shields was a
measure of super speed but she's not
nearly as fast as a train and not nearly
as
strong as someone like Queen Maeve our
homeland err in black Noirs knives and
weapons aren't super special either in
that they're just pretty standard
military issue the reason they're able
to pierce the female skin is because she
doesn't have any invulnerability but as
we do see she has some of Wolverines
other major powers like regeneration so
number aid black noir gutting the female
probably one of the biggest WTF takedown
moves of the seven on the series next to
some of the stuff that homeland er does
in the finale because that takes it to a
whole nother level and just casually
punching criminals a full city block til
they explode like water balloons but the
reason why Frenchy and the female are
both so shocked in this moment is
because yeah it's intense but she's
never bothered to test her abilities
since they rescued her from captivity
but seven the boys now have a version of
Wolverine on the team you learned that
her name is Kimiko what her tragic
backstory is she was stolen from her
home by a gang with her brother the
reason why she got powers is because of
homeland her secret plan to create super
villains around the world using
terrorist cells so that the military is
forced to let superheroes take them down
like okay well finally let you into the
military because we can't bite super
villains with our regular weapons in the
comics she's referred to as the female
of the species most of the stuff you see
her do the big WTF moments are pretty
comic-book accurate they don't change
her that much she does wind up working
with the boys she's still super hardcore
but she's not nearly as bad as some of
the other characters that you meet
during the series 6 the detective
so black noir as the Batman of the 7 is
supposed to have all the same abilities
as Batman he's an expert in martial arts
an excellent detective so this whole
episode is sort of a demonstration of
his detective in Batman like abilities
it's happening after a train finds that
nanny cam footage of them blackmailing
his girlfriend pop claw also a more
literal Wolverine parody because popping
the claws but the reason why a train
goes to black noir to solve this problem
first is because he doesn't want
homeland her to find out
just because he's terrified like he's
told home later that he's going to fix
the situation but he keeps messing up
and every time during the series when a
member of the 7 is called into a private
meeting with homeland err they always
play it as if any second home leader
could turn and laser them through their
face or just pop their heads right off
their shoulders so you see
black noir going around the city hitting
all of their secret bases in another
reason why I think that they've changed
black noir from the comics significantly
is because of the way this scene goes
down like he goes around Batman style
based to base Frenchie's old girlfriend
calls him and says he's on to us
in the comics black noir has a lot of
secret abilities that would enable him
to do that at SuperSpeed there'd be no
point in him going around slow style so
I don't think that the TV show is trying
to mislead us too much with what we've
seen from black noir so far like what
you see is mostly what you get because
five part of the joke of the character
is that he's the other Golden Boy who
can do no wrong like late in the series
after home Lander gets pissed about the
boys being one step ahead of them in a
train being completely incompetent the
deep has also royally screwed up they
find out about star lights relationship
with Hughie he's giving them all the
business like he's gonna kill them at
any second but pauses in the middle of
his rant yelling at them to compliment
black noir for his perfect work
downright sloppy not you and why you've
been great this is just another joke
about how amazing Batman always is for
there's a whole bunch of real-world meta
Batman black noir jokes he's supposed to
be the most badass member of the group
but there are several scenes through the
series where you see him being totally
chill and funny with a sense of humor
that you do not see from Bruce
wayne/batman in the comics like looking
totally ridiculous during a meeting
trying to casually drink from a straw
through his mask which covers his face
because one of the things about the
character is that he never takes his
mask off even the other members of the
seven don't know what he looks like
underneath that mask you see black noir
has a love for Asian cultures they make
a joke about how popular Batman movies
are in real life when Seth Rogen plays a
director in Universe working on his
first black noir movie said in what they
call the Vox Cinematic Universe their
version of the DC Cinematic Universe he
casually signs autographs for fans of
superhero conventions and in the finale
you see him casually sit down to the
piano next to the player and just stared
him without a word until he flees in
terror and then starts beautifully
playing this complex piano piece like oh
crap he's super cultured super
mysterious and totally hilarious so 3 a
lot of these things about the care
why I think they've changed him
significantly from the comics because in
the comics he is probably one of the
worst most sadistic twisted characters
of the entire series the reason he's
written that way in the comics is
because that version of the character is
meant to be a darker parody of Batman
like the writer makes black noir a
psychopath who's mentally insane as a
way to comment on Batman in the comics
being dark twisted and possibly mentally
insane the comic-book hype sup this big
battle between black noir and homeland
er a parody of Batman vs Superman like
who would you expect to take down
Superman if he ever lost his [ __ ] Batman
would be the first guy you go to but all
these funny moments and scenes with
black noir during the series are big
changes from the comics so - it's all
about Superboy in the way they changed
the season one ending scene in the
comics homeland her son is killed by
butcher right after he's born basically
a fetus coming right out of the womb and
that's it that's the end of butchers
wife and home Landers baby but on the TV
show his wife is still alive in
present-day and now home Lander has this
son who seems like he has most of the
same powers as home Lander to the same
degree that Conner Kent Superboy has
some of Superman's powers so number one
that's why I think they're making a huge
change to the ending of the series black
noir ending homeland is ending their
Batman vs Superman moment in favor of
giving some of that story to his son
like early prediction the son will be
critical in stopping homeland err
because in order to stop someone like
homeland her you need someone as strong
or stronger than him and to top it all
off they kind of pulled back on some of
the depraved things that the characters
do in the series particularly black noir
because in the comics he is so much
worse he's gone full-blown cannibal but
post all your black noir theories in the
comments do you think that they've
actually changed him a bunch from the
comics and do you think that means that
they'll also change the ultimate ending
of the series it just because a lot of
people probably have not read the comics
be careful when you're posting spoilers
about the comic book I will do more
videos for the series in the next week I
got so many requests on my last video
I'm glad that you guys are all digging
it so much but click here for the boys
season 2 teaser trailer and click here
for my breakdown
Avengers what if comic-con trailer
footage and Marvel Zombies thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
and see you guys tonight
you
[Music]